[Applause]
because why would you why would you do
that I don't know maybe cuz I don't want
anyone to see that you just hooked up in
the dungeon cattle just make it a potion
that's actor writer and convenien
keegan-michael key he's channeling of
course Luther president Trump's anger
translator on The Late Show with Stephen
Colbert the award-winning sketch comedy
show key & peele made Luther famous and
aired for five seasons on Comedy Central
now he is making his New York theatre
debut in Hamlet at the Public Theater
he plays Hamlet's best friend Horatio he
also stars in a new Netflix series
called friends from college he portrays
Ethan Turner a writer who moves to New
York City and reconnects with college
friends 20 years after graduation I have
to go there's something I really need to
tell you what are you in love with me
you leave in your wife show me John I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm just I'm really
stressed about - is he okay yeah he's
fine but his school wants me there so
how about if we talk about that when I'm
back in Chicago I work on the 14th or we
could talk about it in the beginning of
September when I'm in New York for the
rest of my life because Lisa and I are
moving back there
what why for the past decade I've been
tracking Lisa around for all my teaching
jobs and she was ready to come back home
so friggin right that the friend group
is back Ryan group is back friend group
again Michael joins us now here at the
desk welcome thank you glad it's good to
be back yeah so let's talk about all the
stuff that you're doing
beginning with Hamlet you're playing
Horatio yes why you've always wanted to
play that character yes yes it's
interesting I I thought I should set my
sights a little lower
there's something about Hamlet
something about Horacio he's first of
all you get to live that's the thing
everybody else tracks or you get to live
but I also think Horatio's this
interesting character he's like the
greatest qualities in a dog he's loyal
he's friendly he's helpful he's
dedicated and so I strive and in my real
life I strive to be like Horacio I feel
like if everybody was like Horacio the
world would be a better place yeah you
trained in Shakespeare doctors degree in
fine arts and acting and from Penn State
and I did my undergrad my whole all my
education was theater and I was a
dramatic actor my and I thought it was
gonna be in a dramatic actor my entire
career and it ended up being that this I
went on this 19 year detour and sketch
comedy that was delightful and wonderful
but actually unexpected people loved the
key and peele will it ever come back it
will probably come back in some form but
I don't know because my partner has
retired from sketch comedy he's a
filming he's a filmmaker all know from
the wonderful get out the film get out
this year but I just want everybody to
know that so Peele directed get out
right I promise I will not take the
credit
even though 25 you know love your work
man that movie was great I saw you last
night I went to the show yes and you do
inject so and what is very dense
Shakespearean text you do inject moments
of levity lightness and how do you do
that when it's a four hour sustained
play that must be a heavy lift doesn't
it I think what what what what our
director Sam gold told us to do was
first of all he said I his opinion the
best the best versions of Hamlet he's
ever seen have always been the funniest
versions I've always been the ones with
the most humor Hamlet is such a a man of
such mental adroitness that a person
who's that smart
has to have humor in the somewhere
within them and and so we wanted to
infuse humor into the DNA of this
particular production so that you don't
feel the four hours so that the more
because I think very often the more
specific you are very often the funny or
something gets even if you don't mean it
to be funny the more specific the more
honed in the languages the more you find
humor in it or you go okay that was a
clever turn of phrase so that by the
time you get to the real deep dark stuff
at the end you're not feeling down
you're not feeling trodden or it doesn't
feel laden to you you go like oh gosh
everybody died did it take you to do
that though and sort of translating this
text into oh this is how he would have
said it I think it was now a lot of it
was I I used to get in trouble during
rehearsal for being to mid-atlantic and
to Shakespearean you know yes Midlands
and you know like Keegan you're dropping
all your R's I just have yeah exactly
yeah yeah yeah and what they wanted what
the director really wanted from
everybody I want your version of Horatio
I want Keegan Horatio I don't don't
don't put any loftiness on it though you
didn't watch anybody else no didn't
watch anybody else I didn't want anybody
else to do it i okay I confess I was
shooting movie in Vancouver maybe I
watched Kenneth Branagh does Hamlet
wants me but but there's an earnestness
that that you can kind of wash over the
character and he didn't want that
because I wanted a specific Midwestern
Detroit
Keagan Hamlet that does Oscar Isaac says
Hamilton as Hamlet make it easier yes it
does because his language is that he
makes the language so accessible and he
makes it so contemporary that you just
feel like you're doing a 21st century
play that's part of Austria talent is
that yeah and maybe you felt this way
Margit less than you like are they still
doing Shakespeare because I know a lot
of people go but I'm understanding this
why am i understanding this so it makes
it easier trully he makes it so
accessible he makes it makes you allows
you to feel the emotions you want to
feel because everything is happening it
doesn't feel remote it doesn't feel 400
years old oh now that you've done
Horatio do you think you can do Hamlet
yeah I think I feel like I guess I'm
learning the lines don't forget what's
out ask yeah
I'm learning the lines as I go and it
every night the familiarity makes it
less formidable let's talk about friends
from college what I think a lot of
people will find really interesting
about this it's a ensemble piece but
it's very diverse and if you look at the
poster there yeah it's very diverse and
that race is not a factor race and
ethnicity is not a factor at all in how
these group of friends interact with
each other is sex a factor very much a
factor I think it's you know what it is
flight it's just and we try to do this
in key and Peele - it's a very humans
it's a human story it and and we were
trying to tell human stories but my big
thing is always tell human stories and
if you happen to have melanin in your
skin terrific because that's what
everyone's going to relate to I don't I
want everyone to be able to watch and
glean something from everything I do
it's not a black piece or a Hispanic
piece but there's there are there are
things that you learn from the textures
of other cultures but it's just people
trying to get through in the world how
well did you get to know President Obama
I got to know Obama actually relatively
well I'd say we're acquaintances plus
one yeah I'll go let's say that and I
would like to see more of him like I'd
love for him to come see the Hamlet you
know did he have comedic town timing
very much so at the White House
Correspondents Dinner I thought he was
unbelievable and he had been breaking he
was breaking in the rehearsing remember
everything everything Salman bin Laden
was that night was that that was that
was the year prior yeah and I remember
because all the writers I knew the
writers are the funniest joke well he's
just killing the biggest threat to
America right now solution put your
jokes aside for a minute great to have
you keegan-michael key Hamlet is at the
Public Theater in New York City through
September 3rd